hey guys as you know I didn't get a
video up today because the internet is
[ __ ] here so as punishment for not
preparing and working ahead I'm gonna
have beautify here the [ __ ] out of him
well okay he's going to only chance
again he's gonna slap me in the face I'm
so excited it's up to him and how hard
this punishment is to be done so can you
say to the camera that you're proving I
approve it was my idea
they just got really excited about Jax
holding the phone um he's next
do I go that way no [ __ ] slack you're
not a pimp
I don't want bad boy I don't like em
could you step away from the time
wardrobe
I want your Schmitt face to smack into
that oh my they know that's fine
oh I feel like though I should type you
that way in case you fall over the bed I
bet you're just gonna slap me so hard
I'm gonna tumble up with your left hand
thing stop being a [ __ ] and slap me
alright say something me come on I can't
love you you didn't earn any of your
subscribe ah I was gonna have that
smells good son that's a hefty slap okay
oh so and that is one slap oh yeah
alright I can take slide I'll return by
my turn yeah video wait for this forever
yeah I know you have [ __ ] [ __ ] at
the time Flyers dead I'll never be your
boyfriend
oh it's like oh come on in yard oh
that's like half and half it's okay
thank you
you're supposed to hate me no no it's
cool I deserve this because obviously I
didn't get a video up so when I get back
from New York or if I can do it later
today maybe I can get them to slap me on
the ass tomorrow hopefully way thanks
guys yeah smooches yes subscribe to
beautify honey needs it desperately yeah
okay bye ladies like ah